There’s nothing quite like hearing a fart,
and knowing the painful inevitability of it
crossing your nose’s path. But, if you could
react quickly enough, do you even stand a
chance to escape it’s smell? Could you outrun
a fart?
If you’re trying to outrun the sound...good
luck! Sounds are vibrations that travel through
particles in a wave, and their speed is dependent
on the medium they’re travelling in. For
example, sound travels 4x faster in water
than air, because the particles are much closer
to together, meaning they more quickly transmit
vibration energy. When travelling through
air at sea level and 15℃, sound travels
at 340 m/s - way faster than the fastest man
on earth, Usain Bolt, who can only move 12.4
m/s. Not even the fastest animal, the peregrine
falcon which can travel 82 m/s - could soar
past the sound of it’s own toot.
But it’s the smell that most are concerned
about escaping anyway, and here’s where
it gets a bit more complicated. Unlike sound
waves and visible light which travel through
the air, smell is made up of the odour compounds
that create the air. When you cut the cheese,
odor molecules travel through the air and
up your nose where they bind to odorant receptors.
And each individual has a unique set of receptors,
meaning we all perceive smell differently.
At the basic level, smells travel through
the process of diffusion whereby particles
move from area of high concentration to low
concentration, until reaching a state of equilibrium.
But the composition of every fart is unique,
based on the food you ate, your gut bacteria
breaking it down, and the swallowed air you
took in. Yup - farts are like snowflakes;
each with it’s own variance. But the average
fart tends to be composed of 59% nitrogen,
21% hydrogen, 9% carbon dioxide, 7% methane,
3% oxygen, and only around 1% is made up of
the smelly stuff. Even knowing this, we would
still need to know the concentration at the
source, the temperature, air pressure, and
wind movement in the room - which even in
a very still room is significant. Anecdotal
evidence on the internet suggests that farts
are ejected at about 3 m/s, but there is little
scientific evidence to back this up.
However, if we take into account the temperature
of the gas, pressure and kinetic energy of
molecules, then the kinetic theory of gasses
can help predict the average speed of a gas
molecule. But since a fart is made up of many
molecules, let’s just focus on one of the
smellier parts: skatole. If we use the kinetic
theory of gasses, assume that the fart is
at body temperature, and then we plug in the
molar mass of skatole, we calculate that the
smelly skatole may be travelling around 243
m/s! Which is obviously faster than a human
can move.
Of course, these molecules aren’t travelling
in an uninterrupted line but are constantly
colliding into other air particles and physical
matter. As a result the gas cloud as a whole
travels much slower still guided by diffusion.
And it doesn’t take into account any air
movement like wind or the ejection direction,
which could either work for or against you.
So, while you certainly can’t run faster
than the absolute speed of smelly fart particles,
with a little luck, you might be able avoid
the fart itself!
Want more fart science? Check out our videos
“Are Silent Farts More Deadly?” and “Why
Do We Like Our Own Farts?” By clicking the
screen or using the link in the description.
And subscribe for more weekly science videos!